we have focused a lot on the story on
one of the most important and largest
parts of the tragic coronavirus deaths
that have happened in America yes we
know that the virus attacks the old
primarily but the level of acceptance
and in some rare cases what appears to
have been outright negligence that led
to some of these deaths certainly cries
out for some inquiry and some
investigations so it's easy to see that
something is just not right in some of
these situations and we owe these people
the veterans among them and their
families some answers that are better
perhaps than this one that we heard
today from the governor of New York he
was asked about the 139 New Yorkers in
long-term care who died and that was
just on Saturday here's what he said
see two families who suffered losses in
sight nursing homes and they're looking
for accountability and they'd like to
see justice how do we get justice for
those families who had 139 deaths what
is justice who can we prosecute for
those deaths
nobody older people vulnerable people
are going to die from this virus and
that is a fact and that is not going to
change about 5600 New Yorkers died in
nursing homes of kovat 19 and new
nationwide data says that 41 percent of
all the deaths in America from this
virus are traced to nursing homes or
assisted living facilities 41 percent so
joining me now is the person in charge
of overseeing these facilities at the
federal level administrator for the
Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services Seema Verma also a member of
course of the White House Task Force on
the virus thank you so much for being
here tonight
Seema good to have you with us yeah
thanks for having me good to see you
Martha so good to see you so it's what's
your reaction you know when you hear
that from Governor Cuomo and I've spoken
to families who have lost loved ones in
this situation
that is not as a statement from him that
is going to give many of them a whole
lot of comfort
Martha every life is precious and that's
why this administration started very
early in making sure that we were doing
everything we can to keep nursing home
residents safe they deserve that older
individuals have taken care of us are
their whole lives and they deserve to be
respected and to be protected so I guess
when you say you've been doing
everything that you can I'm curious what
that exactly means what have you from
the federal perspective mandated did you
mandate testing right away did you surge
tests to all of these facilities around
the country right away that's one
question that I have what what did you
mandate in terms of testing and wetting
so starting from a broad oversight from
the very beginning we recognize that
nursing homes were going to be
vulnerable and we put out a series of
guidance and recommendations to our
nursing homes we also have been working
with state and local officials just as
level-set the responsibility and
oversight of nursing homes as both the
federal and state government on the
federal level we set the guidelines and
the states are actually boots on the
ground they do the inspections and
they're responsible for licensing and
one of the things that we did very you
only do let me just clarify that so you
are not you would say that you do not
have any ability to mandate anything
that happens at these facilities is that
what you're saying usually cannot
mandate anything at them the federal
government sets requirements and so if a
nursing home is in violation of any of
those requirements there's obviously
sanctions or civil monetary penalties
and we also have the ability to revoke
our Medicare and Medicaid payment but
the licensing of these activities and
their ability to to operate rests with
the state so it's a joint federal-state
partnership all right so one of the
things that I've heard from people that
I've spoken to our nursing homes is that
in the beginning they couldn't get the
tests that they wanted then when they
got the tests that they wanted it would
take at least a week to turn them around
so they would have patience together in
these sometimes close quarters where you
know they're waiting a week and by that
point it's too late and the the disease
is the virus has begun to spread you
know throughout that entire hallway so
why is it you know having seen what we
saw in Italy we knew that the first hot
spot was Washington State in the home
there why wasn't it that the the best
tests that we had were not surged to
these neat these facilities which we
knew housed the most vulnerable
population in the whole country right
away well one of the things that we call
on you know weeks ago is a call to
action for state and local leaders to
emphasize and to work with nursing
facilities to make sure that they had
access to testing one of the things that
we did on the federal level was to
increase reimbursement for testing and
actually for the first time pay for labs
to go out to nursing homes to collect
samples so on the federal level we've
we've made that recommendation we've
called to action
and you've seen a response to that we've
seen governor's across the country
testing their nursing homes you've seen
that increase in reimbursement and
because of that we're seeing more and
more nursing homes being tested but
today we issued guidelines for state
local officials and nursing homes about
reopening and it's decided to stop short
of mandating any of it you know I'm
looking at a quote from the president he
was asked if you wanted to consider a
nationwide mandate for testing at
nursing homes last week and he said I
would mandate it if you'd like I think
it's an important thing to do and we
know that that vice president Pence has
talked about it too but up to this point
can you just clarify for me that the
federal government has not mandated that
these facilities test and provided them
with the ability to do so is that a
correct statement we've put these
recommendations and guidelines for
states and for the nursing homes we've
talked to the nursing home associations
they're supportive of these efforts
governors are supportive of these
efforts but if we felt like there wasn't
compliance and we could move towards a
requirement but at this time we feel
like the recommendation around testing
as a baseline so we not only want to
test the residents will we also want to
make sure that all of the health care
staff in that nursing facility is also
tested as well and that's going to
everybody wants to make sure that that's
what's happening but from what I'm
learning looking into this it's spotty
some places don't have the test in E and
some places did have the test that they
need with regard to the other question
that I have you know that we in the
initial surge of this when we knew these
were the most vulnerable places in the
whole country and then we built these
FEMA facilities with a lot of extra beds
and then it was you know sort of good
news that all the beds weren't needed
and in some cases we have pictures of
all of these going up these incredible
facilities that we heard about and then
you know mate April 30th you have the
comfort in New York City which was
converted to be a co vyd facility
sailing away from New York at that point
why was and if the answer is that this
is not a federal question it really
falls to the governor and I've asked you
know New York officials this as well but
what do you say to why those individuals
weren't taken out of the nursing homes
where they were infecting people all up
and down their corridor and put in these
places that were such a wonderful
facility that was built by the Army
Corps of Engineers that's right and in
Martha it's very clear federal
guidelines make it very clear that when
you are discharging a patient from the
hospital
there's the obligation to make sure that
that patient is being discharged whether
it's going home or going back to the
nursing home that the nursing home has
the capacity to deal with those patients
and so if a nursing home is saying we're
not able to accept that patient then
that's something that has to be taken
into consideration when doctors and
hospitals are discharging patients from
hospitals they have to make sure that we
are discharging the patient to a place
and can accommodate their needs and if
that person is still unfortunately have
been positive then they need to be
isolated and we need to make sure that
that isolation and care can continue in
the most appropriate setting well we
know that in New York in New Jersey the
epicenter of the virus of both of those
governor's insisted that those patients
when they were released from hospitals
went back into the nursing homes and I
haven't been able to get an answer to
why they weren't sent to these other
facilities because we know that once
they went back to these places they
infected other people
whoo you know some of whom ended up
dying as a result of that so it's it's
tragic and it is you know in my mind one
of the most important questions to be
answered in this whole thing 40% of the
people we've lost have been in these
nursing homes Seema Verma thank you very
much good to speak with you tonight
Thank You Martha thanks for having me
tonight